okay I've got some clips to play for you
today from a recent interview that
right-winger ben shapiro did on Joe
Rogan's podcast we could do 30 minutes
on all of the caveats about Joe Rogan
and Ben Shapiro we can talk about Joe
Rogan effectively according to some
serving as a gateway to the alt-right we
can talk about the ways in which ben
shapiro
appears to be very informed and
convincing but often says things that
don't make sense I've said before if you
listen really closely to ben shapiro you
will often realize that even though he's
speaking confidently and he's speaking
quickly that what he's saying is
actually not making that much sense and
i have a couple of really funny examples
of that and Joe Rogan I don't even know
that Joe Rogan realized how much he
exposed ben shapiro in the clips that
i'm going to play for you today so to
set it up this gets to a portion of the
interview between ben shapiro and joe
rogan where i guess i would say it's
about ben shapiro religious beliefs and
Joe Rogan's asking questions about Ben
Shapiro's Orthodox Judaism and mostly
they're talking about homosexuality
which I'm going to get to a little bit
later in the clip but Joe and Ben sort
of agree that there are some historical
reasons why things became Commandments
in the Old Testament for example they
agree that there are some historical
realities at the time which explained to
us like for example the Bible mentions
man shall not lie with another man or
whatever the phrase is I don't even care
but the the line that's pointed to that
people point to is saying homosexuality
is bad that wasn't in the Bible because
the people who wrote the Bible thought
in a thousand years maybe there will be
gay people it was there because they saw
gay people at the time and they decided
we're gonna put something in the Bible
about it okay the the the example
doesn't really matter but the idea is
the Bible reflects things that were
happening at the time so Joe Rogan
brings up a sort of naturalistic
explanation for why eating pork is not
in Judaism it's also not okay in Islam
the same analysis would sort of apply
related to the cooking temperature of
pork and bacteria and whatever you'll
hear it in a second and Ben Shapiro says
very clearly he doesn't like
naturalistic explanations for this stuff
check it out and pay really close
attention here to what ben shapiro says
like the very reason to have a
commandment is because certain people in
your community are behaving in a
particular way presumably right there's
no commandment not to take your head and
shove it in a meat grinder well this is
also the argument against pork is
because they didn't understand
trichinosis they understand you have to
cook the meat to 145 degrees and pork
parasites which are very dangerous for
people so I'm not a huge fan of
naturalistic explanations for religion
so I think that's a good one though for
pork I mean I don't know like I think
you could make an argument maybe okay
ben shapiro says very clearly he's
against naturalistic explanations for
religion meaning he doesn't like
explaining religious precepts with sort
of real-world justifications from nature
ben shapiro said very clearly he's
against that fine so then about 90
seconds go by okay this next clip is
from 90 seconds after what I just played
for you and ben shapiro gives a
naturalistic explanation for Moses
parting the Red Sea he just said he's
not into naturalistic explanations and
here he gives a naturalistic explanation
90 seconds later do you think it
resurrected no that's not that's not a
Jewish belief okay just one shot yeah no
no no not by Jesus they're their ones
the old women yeah you've got Moses
splitting the sea and all that what do
you think happen there what do I think
happened there yeah well I'll go with my
mana D and explanation that there was a
mean it says in the Bible there was a
strong east wind so there's a
naturalistic explanation for a physical
phenomenon that makes sense I mean
that's what Maimonides is constantly
trying to do is read nature back into
the Bible mmm yeah he says it's the
miracle of Moses parting the Red Sea and
he naturalistically
explains
wind in the Red Sea area which is a very
common naturalistic explanation for the
parting of the Red Sea in the old
testament which he just said he's not in
favor of he's not in favor of those
types of explanations except all of a
sudden when he is and this reminds me of
naturalistic explanations for Noah's Ark
if you talk to some religious people
about Noah's Ark they'll say no you know
we've sort of identified where there
were floods at the time based on
geological records and here is how it
all could have worked so on and so forth
never explains how some of the species
need salt water and some need fresh
water and how did they get all of that
onto the ark for the time it had to be
there it doesn't explain how there are
carnivorous animals and if you only had
two of each species didn't any of them
get eaten did you start with more than
two and they were eaten down to two or
did carnivorous animals get fed some
kind of Soylent or vegan diet during
none of that stuff is explained but at
least the the specifics of the flood are
sometimes explained naturalistically
with Noah's Ark this is the same thing
here naturalistically explaining the
parting of the Red Sea after saying he
doesn't like naturalistic explanations
now I know some people will say David
hold on ben shapiro says
Maimonides gives that explanation it
doesn't matter ben shapiro said he's not
for naturalistic explanations of
religious stories or miracle or miracles
or phenomena and then 90 seconds later
he insta flips on himself and it was a
missed opportunity actually for Joe to
call him out on that so then they get
back to homosexuality and to Dave
Reubens marriage to his husband Dave
Rubin is a cultural critic and political
commentator who engages in the battle of
ideas where the free market allows the
best ideas to float to the top sort of
like fat on on milk or butter or
whatever anyway they get to Dave Reubens
marriage which Ben Shapiro has been
saying for a while how he would not go
to Dave's room Dave Reubens wedding or I
guess wouldn't have gone if they had
been friends at the time I don't know
that they knew each other at the time
but he'd still have Dave and his husband
over for dinner because going to the
wedding
goes against his religious beliefs but I
guess having them to dinner doesn't and
Joe Rogan just exposes the idiocy idiocy
of it so easily right and one of the
things that I the reason I keep coming
back to the governmental regulation
point is because my view is that if your
view of discipline is not my view of
discipline good on you
right like go do what you want to do
like I've never had a conversation with
Dave Rubin about about him being a gay
guy right but you did say that you like
wouldn't go to his marriage right well I
said right as a religious person I can't
say I can't actively participate in
something that I consider to be a sin
but I would go out to dinner with Dave
and his husband anytime like my wife and
I would do that of course we'd have him
over to our house with his husband
there's no you don't find any
contradiction between your religious
perspective and your personal
perspective in that regard that you
would though you wouldn't be there for
religious reasons but that you would be
there for personal reasons like if it
wasn't would you go to the after party
like if you wouldn't go to the wedding
would you go to the after-party anything
that was a celebration of same-sex
marriage no wow so anything but like if
we go to the party no I mean there's a
barbecue the next day you know it's and
again like I'm not sure why I'm not a
good party person so I'm not sure why
anybody would want me at their party
frankly I haven't been to a party with
you but I went to a dinner party with
you that's true we had a great time and
that was a good time that's good that's
a funny picture man that isn't I don't
know what the [ __ ] to think about that
picture we had is certainly true Eric
and Jordan so Joe Rogan's being sort of
funny about it
he's very pressing Atlee exposing the
absurdity of what ben shapiro is saying
going out to dinner with a gay couple
who you recognize as a gay couple is
recognizing the idea that they are a
couple which his religion considers a
sin it's a very sort of mealy-mouthed
weird gray area to say well I wouldn't
go to the wedding ceremony because then
I would be endorsing something my
religion believes as a sin and I
wouldn't go to the wedding reception and
just have dinner because I would be
recognizing the sin but like a couple
days later I'd go to dinner with them as
a couple which of course is recognized
as a couple which his religion believes
it is a sin but that would sort of be
okay in been Shapiro's mind and you know
he says he wouldn't go to anything that
celebrates same-sex marriage I hate to
break it to you but when you go out with
a couple who is married and it's a gay
couple you're effectively celebrating or
at minimum recognizing something that
your religion teaches you is a sin it is
the fence sitting that is so
mealy-mouthed
that I found just laughable here and
here Joe Rogan actually does a really
good job when he says what about the
reception what about a barbecue the day
after like at what point is going to
hang out with dave rubin and his husband
disconnected enough from the fact that
it's a gay couple that's married under
the law that you can sort of rationalize
it post facto in a way that feels okay
for what your religion teaches this is
why it's all nonsense and really nice
job by Joe Rogan in exposing it and by
the way Ben Shapiro is welcome on the
show anytime he's been on before think
at this point he probably yeah I think
he's too big for the David Pakman show
at this point he's got bigger fish to
fry but open invitation for him anytime
follow me on Twitter at D Pakman follow
the show on Twitter at David Pakman show
I would love to hear from you about this
of course Donald Trump's brain sort of
weirdly glitched again and he spoke
total nonsense yesterday to an audience
at the prescription drug abuse and
heroin summit of 2019 and we've talked
about this before and before I show you
the video that the most important thing
I want to explain is that this is
different than when George W Bush said
weird things like I'm not trying to
defend george w bush nor do i think he
deserves any defending but in this case
the comparison is sort of instructive
when bush said something like when wings
take dream he just messed up a quote
right when Bush said fool me once shame
on you fool me you can't get fooled
again
there wasn't an indication that his
brain was glitching any more than his
sort of normal state of cognition but
with Donald Trump these very
strange glitches are starting to pile up
and much like dr. John Gartner has been
predicting when we've interviewed him on
the program they're happening more and
more frequently check this out from
yesterday we will not solve this
epidemic overnight but we will stop
it's just nothing gonna stop West no
matter how you cut it I know some of the
people in this room nothing stops you
nothing stops you I can tell you we will
never stop until our job is done and
then maybe we'll have to find something
new and I hope that's gonna be soon but
we will succeed we have results that are
unbelievable seems to be kind of a
combination of miss reading his
teleprompter and getting visibly
confused and there aren't ever really
good explanations for these and the
common thread is that you see in Trump's
expression the slight recognition that
he knows he's doing or saying something
a little bit odd but it's just beyond
his control in a way here's another
example the oranges of the investigation
and I hope that this investigation now
which is finished
it's totally finished no collusion no
obstruction I hope they now go and take
a look at the oranges or the oranges of
the investigation the beginnings of that
investigation you look at the origin of
the investigation where it started how
it started who started it whether its
McCabe or Co me or a lot of them where
does it go how high up in the white
house did it go you will all get
Pulitzer Prizes okay you're gonna all
get Pulitzer Prizes you should have
looked at it a long time ago and that's
the only thing that's disappointing to
me about the Muller report the Muller
report
I wish covered the oranges how it
started the beginnings of the
investigation we still never really got
an explanation for that or for
god-blessed the united sates originally
there was speculation about dentures
then Trump's medical report didn't say
anything
about dentures rich dudes also usually
get dental implants not dentures
remember this one
let us rethink old assumptions and open
our hearts and minds to possible and
possibilities and finally I asked the
leaders of the region politically
religious
Israeli and Palestinian Jewish and
Christian and Muslim to join us in the
noble quest for lasting peace thank you
god bless you god bless Israel God bless
the Palestinians and god bless the
United States
thank you very much and then there are
these other examples when Trump couldn't
find his limo which was right in front
of him and started wandering off you
might remember that there is the time
that he showed up in the White House to
sign an executive order and then just
walked out of the room without even
signing it look thank you everybody
you're gonna see some very very strong
results very very quickly thank you very
much thank you
Mike Pence had to pretend that they were
planning on signing it in some other
room all along and then there's that
really bizarre moment when Trump just
sort of wandered away from Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu as they were
supposed to do a handshake and a picture
and had to be called back and then maybe
most odd remember when Rudy Giuliani was
literally two feet across the table
directly in front Donald Trump closer
than this camera is to me right now and
Trump was looking around the room for
him with that I want to introduce
Giuliani and he's going to be working
with Jared Kushner and with Tom Basu
very important thing to him to what he
does and maybe I'll ask Rudy to say a
few words we could really do these all
day there's walking away from the
Argentinean president at the g20 in
Argentina there is a lot of this stuff
and the theme is barely holding it
together visibly struggling to put
together a coherent thought barely able
to finish a sentence barely able to sort
of complete a some kind of logical and
sequential argument never mind stay
remotely on topic and it's not like
anything we've seen before I don't know
what to make of it I don't know what it
is we've had mental health professionals
who say it's a pre dementia state we've
gotten other explanations I don't know
what to make of it but I'm open to
hearing thoughts from you about it so I
actually had no idea Sunday night when I
was preparing the Monday show that I
would end up talking so much about
impeachment this week but every single
day the number of prominent Democrats
and legal experts who are saying
impeachment is justified impeachment is
the correct thing
impeachment debate at minimum if not
proceedings should actually start right
away that number of people is growing
and growing so every day I find myself
with with sort of more to discuss about
this and I don't want to sort of like
rehash the entire
for you every single day in order to
build on it but I'll remind you that
elizabeth warren now says that she
believes impeachment of donald trump is
the right thing there is a growing
number of people some of whom i'll add
to that list today who are saying this
and the point is it's a movement that is
gaining momentum at this point in time
and it's really important to talk about
the distinction between starting a
debate on impeachment in the House of
Representatives and actually filing
impeachment proceedings which would be a
sort of formal investigation culminated
by a vote by members of the Senate about
whether the president should or should
not be removed the mere start of debate
about impeachment would allow a whole
bunch of documents to to be released the
house could debate and decide rather
than to impeach to censure for example
and we could talk about whether
censuring really has any sort of
practical impact on the President of the
United States from what I've been
reading the last couple of days the
answer is basically no but the point is
deciding to start debate about
impeachment does not mean that it must
or definitely will culminate in actual
impeachment proceedings and eventually a
Senate vote about whether or not to
remove the president and in fact there
are people saying have the debate but
maybe go for censure rather than
impeachment but that is all kind of
secondary here and also sort of
increasingly secondary is the discussion
of impeachment as a strategy I've been
talking for more than a year now about
how impeachment as a political strategy
for 2020 or as a political strategy for
removing the president of the United
States is not particularly useful and I
got a lot of critiques over the last few
days
now that the sort of contours of this
impeachment discussion have changed
saying David forget about the strategy
of it for a second it's the duty of
Congress given the evidence that we have
to at minimum debate the impeachment of
the president if not actually file
impeachment proceedings and I want to
sort of focus along those lines today
I'll give you some examples of the
growing voices that are taking a point
of view on this that is very much Pro at
least starting debate on impeachment
pit's jr. is a writer for the Miami
Herald who points out in a new piece
which were linking to that this is not
about strategy but that this is about
right and wrong and that every corner of
government has been corrupted in some
way the Justice Department with William
Barr the press relationship and access
to the White House visa vie Sarah
Huckabee Sanders endless endless lies
including some of which have now been
verified beyond any doubt it's not just
speculation that she lies it's actually
the Moller report says that she lies she
admitted to lying and he goes on to
explain how basically every corner of
government has been corrupted at this
point in time and it is time to impeach
congresswoman Maxine Waters a Democrat
saying straight up on MSNBC yesterday
we're going to have to impeach
congressman Elijah Cummings I told you
yesterday he was sort of of the mindset
of there should be consequences and if
not now when or what would justify
consequences type of statement to sang
on MSNBC yesterday congressman Elijah
Cummings that Trump quote deserves the
mark of impeachment so we're not talking
about strategy here we're talking about
right and wrong we're talking about a
congressional duty to do what it is that
they're supposed to do given the
circumstances and the evidence that we
have but there are also some interesting
strategy articles being released related
to impeachment one example is from
Republican strategist Cheri Jacobus who
argues that impeachment will actually
help Democrats now we'll get at the end
of the show today today's voicemail is
from an angry trumpet who is sort of
begging for Democrats to try to impeach
drum trump believing that this will just
help Trump get reelected in 2020 that's
one perspective what sherry Jacobus is
pointing out is that most Americans many
Americans a plurality of Americans
whatever phrase you want to apply to it
don't have any idea what's in the molar
report in other words most people have
lives most people aren't watching long
congressional hearings even if
the Michael Cohen congressional hearing
had record ratings for such a hearing
the molar report is 450 pages and to the
extent that people see a news story
about it or unfortunately get their
impressions of what's in the molar
report from the bar letter which is a
complete sort of miss miss
characterization of what's in the molar
report that if you actually start debate
on impeachment and move forward on
impeachment even if it doesn't succeed
at removing the president it will inform
people about the content of the Moller
report it will inform people who have no
idea what is actually going on what it
is that is being debated and that has
taken place and that in the long run it
will actually help Democrats and hurt
Donald Trump as we approach the 2020
election now should Democrats take
advice from a Republican strategist
maybe not
you also have Harvard Law Professor
Lawrence tribe who is for sure a
partisan actor but he is someone who
knows a lot about impeachment who says
at this point in time Donald Trump is
impeach able and by that he means
actually removable by a Senate vote on
the basis of impeachment proceedings
started by the house so the last five
days we've seen a very decided shift
here you've seen more and more Democrats
sort of abandoning the Nancy Pelosi
perspective of we shouldn't bother with
him with impeachment Trump's not worth
impeachment whatever other phraseology
she's applied to this since March you've
seen more and more momentum build
Democrats part ways with Nancy Pelosi
and what's clear at this point in time
without knowing exactly how this is
going to play out is that the discussion
about impeachment is not disappearing
next week and it's not disappearing next
month and it's gone beyond the issue of
political strategy which I still believe
to be legitimate to one simply of given
the facts what is supposed to be
Congress's role in adjudicating the
actions of the President of the United
States it's time to start a floor debate
on impeachment and at that point in time
once that has happened Congress can
decide do we want to actually move
forward with articles of impeachment do
want to move forward with censure of the
president or after this debate have we
determined that we're not going to go
any further that should be the immediate
next step and it goes well beyond
political strategy at this point in time
it's become super popular since the
William bar letter was released a few
weeks ago for people on the right and
even some people on the Left who we've
talked about so-called Russia skeptics
to make a really big show out of
demanding apologies from people are you
ready to apologize for being so wrong
about Russia are you ready to apologize
to your viewers to Donald Trump to
everybody else but now that we've
actually gotten the molar report which
we did sort of mid-day late last week on
Thursday almost everything that was
asserted by serious investigative news
outlets and reported by them during the
two years of this investigation
has been confirmed to be true by the
molar report at least to some degree and
I wish I didn't have to do the following
disclaimers and clarifications but I do
because of the political environment in
which were currently operating I need to
be super clear I don't want to confuse
anybody Donald Trump hasn't been caught
personally colluding with Vladimir Putin
nobody was seriously claiming that the
outcome of the Moller investigation was
going to be Donald Trump caught
personally colluding with Vladimir Putin
on the 2016 election as William Barr
Donald Trump's attorney general said
during his press conference last week
no one untrim scam pain personally
participated in Russia's hacking of
Hillary Clinton or the DNC but again
nobody was claiming that Trump's
campaign was specifically involved in
that hacking but now that we've actually
had the time to go through the Muller
report more than 400 450 pages almost of
the Moller report in detail the deniers
if anybody are the ones who owe other
people apologies and I'm going to
explain it to you and let me be super
clear if you're going to write to me and
tell me that I'm wrong and what I'm
telling you here and you haven't
actually looked through the Moller
report you have no basis for telling me
that I'm wrong
because everything I'm going to tell you
today is out of the molar report we had
this two-year campaign by Donald Trump
and the write and even some on the left
to call reporting on Russia fake news to
call serious reports about what Donald
Trump and his people did in the 2016
election and during the investigation
conspiracy theories whatever term you
want to apply to it the molar report
tells us that most of the reports were
accurate at least to a significant
degree and again if you haven't looked
at the molar report then what exactly
are you going to argue with me about
when I know many of you are going to
send me angry messages and comments and
tweets let's start for example with the
Trump Tower meeting Don junior Don
senior right wing news Hannity whoever
else they all said ad nauseam the
meeting was basically nothing it was an
afterthought it's not a story no one
within the Trump Organization campaign
organization was really counting on or
putting much weight on that infamous
meeting with the Russian lawyer the
molar report confirms that Trump jr.
immediately was super interested in this
meeting it was communicated within the
campaign everybody was really eager to
get dirt on Hillary Clinton from the
Russians the reporting on the story was
almost completely accurate despite all
of the denials still doesn't mean Trump
personally colluded with Putin nobody
was seriously saying that was going to
be the outcome the pending information
that they were waiting on was discussed
at campaign staff meetings before the
meeting took place campaign staffers
were sitting around waiting for the
information this was a big deal
internally it was reported about 15
months ago I'm sorry it was reported
more than 15 months ago and the reports
were effectively completely accurate
another example more than a year ago it
was reported that Donald Trump ordered
don McGann the White House Counsel to
fire
Robert Muller and Don McGann reportedly
refused saying we're not going to do
that that would be a bad idea
those reports were called fake news by
Trump it was called fake news by Fox
News and the molar report confirms that
the reports were true it happened
exactly as was reported the Washington
Post back in 2017 reported that Paul
Manafort was briefing government
connected Russians on the Trump Clinton
campaign of 2016
Hannity said you can't trust the
Washington Post they're constantly
reporting false stuff the Moller report
confirms that it was taking place the
briefings were taking place by Paul
Manafort of government connected
Russians exactly as The Washington Post
reported another example remember that
story from BuzzFeed which claimed that
Trump told Michael Cohen to lie to
Congress and it was widely touted as
fake news Trump touting it as fake news
and the enemy of the people and all of
that stuff well if you look at the
actual content of the Moller report it
quote finds that Cohen lied and he did
so at what he believed to be the
president's behest that the president
knew he was giving false testimony and
that the president's lawyers encouraged
that testimony in his report Muller
wrote that Trump's attorney told Cohen
to quote stay on message and not
contradict the president it's
confirmation of the story I could go on
I'll give you just another couple of
examples Russia successfully penetrated
state voting systems it was reported on
way back when it was denied denied
denied the Muller report confirms that
it's true another example WikiLeaks was
reportedly a go-between for Russian
hackers and the dissemination of hacked
information from the Clinton campaign
and the DNC no no no WikiLeaks is just a
clearinghouse of information they're not
political they're not doing anything
with Russia
well the Moller report again confirms
that the reporting was completely
accurate another example and I'm not
going to go on all day with these but
there are so many Trump personally
didn't collude but people under him
tried to collude like for example Don
junior when it came
Don Jr coordinating the Trump Tower
Russia meeting the molar report actually
says that it appears Don jr. was too
dumb to know what he was doing might be
criminal quote from the report the
office considered whether this evidence
would establish a conspiracy to violate
the foreign contributions ban
solicitation of an illegal foreign
source contribution or the acceptance or
receipt of an express or implied promise
to make a foreign source contribution
there are reasonable arguments that the
offered information would constitute a
thing of value within the meaning of
these provisions just like we've been
saying but the office determined that
the government would not be likely to
obtain and sustain a conviction for two
other reasons first the office did not
obtain admissible evidence likely to
meet the government's burden to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that these
individuals acted willfully meaning with
general knowledge of the illegality of
their conduct and second the government
would likely encounter difficulty
proving beyond a reasonable doubt that
the value of the promised information
exceeded the threshold for a criminal
violation Donald Trump jr. did it but he
was too dumb to reasonably believe
according to what Muller says that he
was committing a crime the other glaring
revelation from the report is that a ton
of people lied to investigators and
aren't being charged I'll give you an
example Secretary of Education Betsy
DeVos his brother Eric Prince who
famously ran that mercenary firm
Blackwater before it was renamed
multiple times testified under oath and
lied many times Prince said he had no
official or unofficial role in the
campaign or transition but it turns out
he had multiple meetings with high-level
campaign officials at Trump Tower
including with people like Don Jr
clearly this is at minimum an unofficial
role in Trump's transition and campaign
he claimed that when he went to the
seychelles in January of 2017 it was to
meet with clients from the United Arab
Emirates turns out that it was actually
Trump associated individuals who set up
those meetings not the UAE and
another lie to investigators prints
claimed under oath that he never
communicated with Steve Bannon regarding
the UAE or us-russia relations well we
now know of text messages between Eric
Prince and Steve Bannon during the time
that Prince was in the UAE it's all
spelled out in the Moller report and
again it's all details but these details
continue to expose that lots of people
lied and they are not facing
consequences so are they're fair
criticisms of reporting on the Russia
probe absolutely corporate media was
hyperbolic in many cases corporate media
devoted way too many of these eight or
twelve person panels to the probe sure
I'm on board with you people got carried
away with the probe in terms of
reporting some Democrats got carried
away thinking the probe would ultimately
take down Trump which I've been saying
for more than a year that it would not
but if you look at the reporting from
investigative sources serious ones and
you compare the claims they made to what
is in the molar report most of those
stories were correct so the reporters
who I won't even name who are agreeing
that the molar report confirms the the
coverage was wrong for years I mean
they're just wrong and the molar report
is the proof that they're wrong and the
delusions are running rampant and my
ideal situation is one where forget
about the right because we know that
they're lost I hope that the left can
come together and agree that basically
most of the reporting was right most of
these serious allegations were correct
the expectation that the report would
take Trump down was never reasonable and
that now we can say hey guys we've got
20/20 because otherwise we are going to
see Trump re-elected in 2020 and we will
have another four years of this so once
again I believe that the left is slowly
coming to a consensus agreement the
entire left about what took place and
what didn't took place and it would be
good to do that and to get past the
partisan not even partisan the internal
bickering that has taken over a lot of
sort of enclaves of the left and we've
got to move on to 2020 okay there's
something really in
thing going on the right has been
totally bamboozled by the quite frankly
as I've said before very well done
exoneration campaign that has been waged
by Donald Trump around the Moller report
but if there's any good news to be
gleaned from the reaction to the Moller
report it's that the country overall
doesn't actually seem to have fallen for
it and Donald Trump's approval rating
has dropped to the lowest of 2019 so far
since the Moller report was published
and I've already told you how well
executed Donald Trump's plan was from
the get-go for appealing to his base he
put in William Baris Attorney General
William Bar is an expert in covering up
presidential wrongdoing Barr wrote this
four-page public relations document
which was then used to justify a
nationwide exoneration tour and
right-wing media tour for Donald Trump
and his advisers then the Moller report
actually comes out but before it's
released
William bar gives this propaganda press
conference on Thursday morning
effectively framing Trump as a victim of
a totally unfair investigation that
William bar implied didn't make any
sense to even do from the beginning
that's what they did but as I already
told you when you look at the content of
the Moller report it's extraordinarily
damning to Donald Trump and to everybody
around him it states that there's quote
substantial evidence that Donald Trump
obstructed justice it confirms almost
every major investigative story that was
reported over the last two years related
to the probe and the campaign as we
already talked about at the top of the
show today and it seems that while
Donald Trump's exoneration propaganda
campaign worked really well with his
base it doesn't appear to be working
well with the American public in total
because there's a new reuters/ipsos poll
which has Donald Trump's approval down a
37 percent this is the lowest of 2019
68% of Americans say they are more
likely than before the report
out to believe that Donald Trump or his
cronies committed crimes half the
country believes that Donald Trump tried
to stop the Muller investigation which
is disturbing that it's only 50% it
should be a hundred percent because he
actually admitted to this on national
television so now we have to ask the
question of whether this is good news or
bad news and unfortunately even though
it's good that the molar report
propaganda campaign has not convinced
all of the country it seems to really
have most worked mostly on Donald
Trump's base there's a lot of bad news
here and the bad news is that while it's
good that trumps approval rating is down
as a result of the Moller report because
it should be because the molar report
contains endless damning evidence about
what Donald Trump and the people around
him did his approval rating should have
already been down to just his hardcore
base months ago that it shouldn't
actually move with news like the molar
report what what I mean is that there's
some portion of the population I've
guessed before that it's in the range of
28 to 30 maybe 32 percent which is what
I call the shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
crowd meaning that no matter what Donald
Trump does they're going to support him
even if he shoots someone on Fifth
Avenue as Donald Trump I guess you could
say joked about a couple of times if
you're not in that twenty eight to
thirty percent base you should have been
so disgusted with Donald Trump already
that it shouldn't really move the
approval rating for Donald Trump to be
so exposed as involved in so much
wrongdoing by the Mullah report if you
think back to George W Bush I believe
that his low approval rating ever was
maybe twenty nine percent maybe twenty
eight percent something like that and
that seems to sort of be what I would
call the partisan floor for a president
given how polarized American politics is
twenty eight twenty nine thirty seems to
be kind of like rock bottom no matter
what a president does they're not going
to go below that tax cuts for the rich
should have already dropped anyone
is reacting to the facts should have
already dropped Trump's approval rating
to that rock-bottom broken promise after
broken promise should have already
gotten us down to just that hardcore
base caging kids should have gotten us
down to just that hardcore base trying
to take health care away from tens of
millions of people
inciting white supremacy anti
anti-semitism and xenophobia the fact
that there's anybody left supporting
Trump who's actually influenced by the
news is concerning to me and the the the
sort of the good news it's always good
when the country reacts correctly by
saying oh I just learned about X I no
longer support the president that's good
but the bad news is that Trump still has
more than just his base supporting him
there are people beyond just the Fifth
Avenue shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
crowd who are saying I'm looking at what
Trump is doing and I'm actually deciding
that I like it and that's
extraordinarily concerning and that gets
us to 20/20 I've said this before it
bears repeating
when half the country doesn't vote with
37% approval and 50% turnout you can win
okay
with 18 19 percent of the total voting
public voting for Trump with the
electoral college system that we have
Trump can win reelection easily assuming
that he campaigns in the right places
and gets the votes in in in the right
places which means once again that if we
were waiting for the molar probe to take
down Trump that was always a bad idea as
I've been telling you for years at this
point but it's really time to realize
that 2020 is going to be about turnout
that being said momentum for impeachment
of the president is growing and I'm
going to talk about that after today's
interview I still don't think it's a
good political strategy I still don't
think it's likely to actually do
anything before the November 20 2011
vigor ating what I would call more
serious conversations about impeachment
and we will talk about those later in
the show
after our interview make sure you're
following the show on instagram at david
pakman show make sure you follow me on
instagram as well at david pakman i
actually posted a picture from a
passover seder i attended over the
weekend and it angered a lot of people
check out the comments follow me on
instagram at david pakman quick break
plenty more coming up right after this
okay we suspected that this would happen
and it has steven minuchin 'he's
treasury department has failed to
deliver Donald Trump's tax returns to
Congress by the set deadline the
deadline was Tuesday yesterday lawmakers
got nothing Donald Trump's Treasury
secretary Stephen minuchin said he can't
do it until he knows if the request is
consistent with the law and we're gonna
get back to that statement but if you
haven't been following this I'll remind
you how it all came about congressman
Richard Neal our old congressman in
Northampton Massachusetts does some good
things does some not-so-good things as
we reported on a couple of weeks ago
he's on the House Ways and Means
Committee and there's a law from 1924
which says that members of the House and
Senate who are on tax writing committees
have the ability to request the tax
returns of any individual or corporation
that they want from the Treasury the law
as written is pretty binary it's
something that if you're on the
committee you can do it's not you get to
request it and the president tells you
whether they're okay with you getting
their tax returns or not if the tax
returns happen to be those of the
president it's not you request it and
the Justice Department can get involved
in deciding whether or not you actually
get those tax returns it's not up to the
president it's not up to the Justice
Department the law is pretty simple but
there is one sort of reasonable hitch in
all of this which has come up and it
seems to be implied in the law but as we
know interpreting what is implied by law
is a complicated thing but the argument
that's being made is that implied
implicit in this 1924 law is that if
someone from any of these tax writing
committees is requesting the tax return
of an individual or a corporation that
there should be some kind of legislative
agenda or purpose to requesting those
tax returns it's not totally clear what
that is for Richard Neil requesting
Donald Trump's tax returns you could
argue the legislative purpose is that
depending on what's in Trump's tax
returns Congress might decide they need
to impeach the president of the United
States if they see something in there
that suggests that there has been
wrongdoing or potential criminal of
financial criminality it's a little bit
of a stretch and ultimately this is
going to be a probably fought by courts
and if indeed it gets to the Supreme
Court we know who is increasingly in
charge there and that's Donald Trump
based on the number of appointments he's
made to that course so the way this
might go is government subpoena of the
tax returns remember that this first
request from Richard Neal was just that
it was just a request the next step
would be a subpoena that would start to
get legally messy and if indeed it gets
to the Supreme Court the Supreme Court
is controlled by Donald Trump in the
sense that he now has a three people on
the court that he selected it is one of
the most conservative courts in a very
long time and it's also evidence of two
justice systems what's going on if you
or I as a normal person gets a summons
from the court for some legal documents
for some documents rather or gets a
summons to appear by a certain date if I
ignore that and say you know I'm
considering whether the request is
consistent with the law and in the
meantime I'm not going to give you what
you want or show up when you told me to
I would be arrested and brought to court
or held in contempt until I provide
those documents and eventually short of
the subpoena steven minuchin could
actually be charged with inherent
content contempt of Congress contempt of
Congress and taken into custody
although obviously none of us expect
that that will happen because we have
two justice systems in the United States
of America the the other sort of absurd
detail about
the argument that he's evaluating the
legality of that request or of whether
this conforms with the law the
legislature wrote the law that allows
this and they are using it to request
Trump's tax returns so in a sense at the
base level of course it's consistent
with the law they wrote the law and now
they're using the law for the purpose it
was written that one caveat being does
there have to be a demonstrable
legislative purpose to the request for
an individual's tax returns and is one
required I don't know the answer but if
you read the opinions of a number of
different legal experts they say that
that could actually be a reasonably good
argument the question I get to in the
end is will we ever actually see Donald
Trump's tax returns and I don't know the
answer let me know what you think
will we see Trump's tax returns let me
know on Instagram the shows on instagram
at david pakman show i'm on instagram at
david pakman and we'll take a very quick
break here and be right back